merci monsieur le Président le Président
Madame la Commissaire chers collègues
l'Europe se dotera de
42,5% d'énergie renouvelable d'ici 2030
c'est un objectif quasiment acté dans
Red et bientôt dans cette assemblée que
nous devons respecter si nous voulons
atteindre la neutralité climatique d'ici
2050 le stockage est indispensable pour
pouvoir utiliser nos énergies
renouvelables dans leur entièreté
énergétique j'allais dire sans perdre un
seul électron sans perdre une seule
molécule ce qui est difficile on le sait
pour le stockage de l'électricité la
meilleure énergie est celle que nous ne
consommons pas dit-on non pour moi la
meilleure énergie c'est celle que nous
ne gaspillons pas car nous avons
toujours besoin d'énergie pour faire
tourner notre économie
l'Europe doit renforcer son système
énergétique pour une meilleure
intégration des sources d'énergie
locales renouvelables et non fossiles
j'appelle aujourd'hui à renforcer notre
politique sur le stockage avec un
objectif chiffré clair accompagné de
mesure concrètes pour soutenir les
Européens et renforcer notre autonomie
stratégique ces mesures devront aussi
favoriser la flexibilité du système
électrique au niveau de la demande
optimisons l'utilisation de notre
électricité avec des outils intelligents
et innovants
décarbonations intégration stockage et
flexibilité voici à mon sens les maîtres
mots du futur énergétique de l'Europe
merci